hello and welcome to this video m47 ok
let's go for something else ok so he
wants to play d4 after all it seems nope
ok mmm I don't know this too well g6 st4
so that cannot be correct can rotate it
with h5 in maybe ikea retail so each
three assists reply yeah probably h5 is
just not a particularly great idea
yeah I wonder if he starts going to play
d4 no probably not okay what do I know
not guessing anything
you have this son this should be ok I
guess and I mean age 5 is a bit of a
strange move but is it that terrible
maybe it's going five now ok I can take
rock TX going to be four so I am ok he's
out for 95 that's an interesting move ok
let's get out of this
yeah without h5 I would like my position
but it's such a strange rule yeah I
shouldn't have done that on the other
hand he feels oh wow whoa okay
okay so pawn takes pawn takes yeah this
is this is not great I came then I have
to do this just kind of well yeah not
the ideal solution before still h5 kind
of sticks out this is also intending on
queen bee form depends a bit on the
circumstances but let's see
cannot move their 69 it's really will
get knowing I'd like to get it to c5 of
course but not possible at the moment so
yeah maybe he even has f4 up his sleeve
I tried to not get in gym decisive time
troll f 1 197 yeah
hmm is that so bad doesn't look so bad
actually this room shakes and night
takes is going to play see 5 or what's
the deal
yeah probably yes but don't I don't
really have anything else ok clue before
here is six at the end but it is that
maybe I should have thought about this a
bit more ok it doesn't take just goes
those two mg five
hello okay that wasn't I didn't think
about this at all
near threatened sitting on these six
f6 clean edge 5 take on c5 this card
should be four at the end yeah I don't
know I have to do it it sucks it really
sucks you should be for probably just
wins
maybe it's got these six now oh my god
he sd-6 now making it so easy here this
is what I really hate and I mean losing
is ok but you make it very easy for the
opponent I always hate that
I'm not seeing the wind to be honest for
him but this very likely there is one
maybe just 83 here 8320 41 tween f 2 i'm
kind of holding on probably not for real
but it seems he doesn't find a knockout
check check time morning okay so he's
not threatening to take them I have
rookie one I can sometimes even take
these six what about clean d to
attacking the rook and 42 is a strong I
can go look to you one maybe but ok I
can still go route Lee one like five
hats on time yeah somebody couldn't
finish me off but it feels like he
should this this d6c it is winning with
a three mmm down I was thinking queen d
for rookie won an obie 55 actually does
when so i have to go here to keep an eye
on e 1 e d 1 then and queen age six air
which is pretty much bad this is is this
good enough for white okay that h5 move
one that looks a little bit that was a
bit too funky
that is really a yeah sticking out this
age 50 95 was nice okay i played this um
yeah the computer wants to do this I saw
this line but I didn't like it here this
is kind of line where everything gets
traded but I felt that I'm worse maybe
I'm wrong them yeah I'm not versa we're
taking those two okay so i decided to go
for this but here white is definitely
better and yeah a 497 maybe I should
take with the Queen then after all this
is really a problem see 5 mm i know this
i have 93 what I didn't see that oh my
god but I can just for Kim yeah I was
somehow so much worried about getting
made it here with Queen h5 bush before I
didn't see it I can just do this yeah
now I'm toast check China yeah I'm okay
okay then cool you want this is actually
winning check check check check check
yeah I can take tick write some chatting
pawns check check and ultimately taking
in check check black can run the night
is a very good defender here at the a
pawn wins this actually is a draw
because of this a move I didn't see at
all now I have to perpetual
looky one yeah very young ever ridden
game but um yeah currently I'm happy
with them with winning as some of those
jungle kind of games okay well thanks
for watching